welcome to a discussion about the music
for hedwig and the angry inch
steven trask is a grammy award-nominated
composer musician
and lyricist who composed the music and
lyrics for the musical had to again the
angry inch
and the subsequent film adaptation
his other credits for film include the
station agent
in good company american dreams and
lovelace
stephen thanks for joining us we're
really excited to
talk to you music is such an important
part of this
uh project and we'd love to hear a
little bit about the development
uh let's talk about um you know adapting
your music and songs from the broadway
musical for the big screen
one thing i definitely knew i wanted to
do was
you know the the look on the screen was
going to be much more
vivid and up close
than we had on the stage and this this
the stage costumes
when they were up close they were
serious but there was also a jokey side
to them
but in the movie that was a serious rock
band and i felt like the
something i wanted to do in the movie
was the music really needed to sound
like music that was made by the people
that looked that like that
and put together a really killer band
that was centered on on
um on bob muelled as a guitar player
who was one of my idols from husker dew
and then sugar
who had become a fan of the show and
lived down the street
from the from the jane street theater
and and
you know we hung out pretty regularly
like he came by
saw the end of the show a lot you know
he saw the show a lot in general
brought a lot of musicians that i
respected there
and then he just hung out we became
really close friends i ended up
dog sitting for him a lot which was
convenient because it was right near the
theater
um and then he was he was the
centerpiece of
the recording band so i tried to produce
it with a
slightly less polished sound than the
cast album had
and and just a little more more raw i
know we're going to be
talking to out alex but alex stairmark
he
led us through the process of figuring
out how to get
the sound of the band coming out on the
stage
while shooting so that the extras could
see what it
could feel like they were at a concert
people that played the musicians worked
really hard to learn their parts
and um worked very closely with the
actual musicians
we put on these little fake concerts you
know on the set for the extras
there was a lot of production involved
both on the day and then leading up to
it
besides giving all the players their
their parts you would pre-record john
do a master take of his vocal you would
come we'd comp
what we thought was the ideal vocal and
he would learn that when he sang
live he was singing having sort of
studied what
that master take and then he would sing
about i don't know four or five times
live and then
start lip syncing because how many times
can he sing and then still
act a scene i'm not sure how much of
what we actually
did playing-wise in the movie actually
made it to the film
but um that drummer man he michael iron
off he was just he did he hit
every drum fill he made one mistake and
it haunts him to this day
one symbol he forgot to hit this project
is very interesting to me because it
started out
in in such a simple form such a very
pure form
and then kept expanding from this you
know kind of cabaret
or you know personal appearance act and
then
moving into more of a play and then
moving more into the movie
so i'm just curious what was the feeling
of hedwig for you as the composer as you
were composing these songs
and working on this project over those
years
what was the feeling of that character
that you
musically feel was consistent
like one of the things that hedwig has
that that is sort of like
i mean some of it just comes from me but
and and it's
and inspired by a lot of the same
musicians but as sort of
an eclecticism i listen to a lot of a
lot of different kinds of music
the songwriters that i idolize listen to
a lot of different kinds of music
when hansel puts his head in the oven
early on it's
you know anne murray and debbie boone
and david bowie and eggy pop and
and you know lou reed it's not just the
punk and glam
and avant-garde stuff that that hedwig
life it was an eclectic
mix of things every name checks like
patty smith
and yoko ono but also aretha franklin
and also
laverne baker hedwig's a student of rock
music
you know and and even to the point of
the the
the essay that gets hansel thrown out of
university
is is um is about the aggressive
influence of rock and roll music and
our german philosophy and rock and roll
means they're called you can't always
get what you want
so so um you know it's
this is something that that that that
character was obsessed with
and i think that that that the music is
drawing
however it's expressed um it's drawing
on a lot of different sources at all
all at the same time i think that's why
trying to
translate it to the film it drawn all
those sources but it had a more
the the sound was more start to finish
cohesive
than in the and then in the original uh
off-broadway show where it felt like
where it jumped genres a lot
but we got away with it because we were
on stage we were wearing those costumes
so this was your first feature and and
was this the first exposure you had to
filmmaking in this
in this way where you were a major part
of it like in a professional
sense absolutely i i did a i did a movie
musical
uh in college that was a thesis
uh film for miguel arteta and um
and it won all sorts of awards like film
fest
like berlin film festival and i think it
got a student academy award
it was a similar sort of thing where we
actually like had to put a like
wrote the songs uh recorded the songs
talk them to the actors
perform them on on the screen but it was
obviously with
for no money and with student equipment
um
but for what it was it was celebrated
and and and
i know that they had a copy of it on
buffy the vampire slayer set and they
watched it a lot
according to joss whedon that's true
so it was it had its influence yeah
that's amazing so what was the
transition like for you to go into this
you know
even though it was an independent film
it was it was definitely
you know as you say a professional major
major release
film you know i think i was re i wasn't
i wasn't a kid i did the show for a year
on
at the jane street theater and during
that time we did
all sorts of appearances and we recorded
an album and we tried to launch the show
in some other cities and it didn't work
because
the productions were unwieldy so by that
time i was just sort of like
it was just sort of like walking into a
new room of a house
for me and and with definitely different
responsibilities but it didn't
it didn't feel like oh my god what's
this new thing
it was like oh this new it was very just
very exciting
new ways of doing the thing if that
makes sense
completely i do want to bring alex into
the conversation now so
alex starmark has uh worked as a music
supervisor
editor and producer since 1998
and on projects as varied as the boxer
the ice storm
and of course i began the angry inch his
feature film
directorial debut was a musical kick to
it
pray for rock and roll please welcome
alex steyermark
alex come on board hello
so i i think the first thing you know
music supervisor is one of those
titles that i think people think they
have an idea of what it's like to
supervise music but i don't think they
really know what that
entails on a day-to-day basis so could
you two talk about your working
relationship
and how the composer and music
supervisor work together to
to get a cohesive sound and a cohesive
feel
well i think uh the the job the music
supervisor is
something that is different depending on
the film
and and i think the needs of a movie
dictate what that is and i also think
that different
people bring different skill sets to it
for me it's that uh you know i i had
studied film
but also studied music my whole life so
i always
came at it from the sort of filmmaker
side
with a sensitivity i guess to how music
is created
on this particular film which was a
massive
actually a massive endeavor given the
amount of music in the film and the fact
that
both john and stephen were making their
first film
it was a very complex project and
i i had sort of become known as someone
who was good with
on-camera films with on-camera
performances as well so
um i was brought in by the
originally by the producer of the film
christine veteran to
meet and talk with stephen and and john
about
about the film uh it also helped that uh
i had had a lot of music production
experience
also i had seen the show at the jane
street theater so
what seemed to be one of the challenges
of of the film was to translate
the intensity of what it was like to
actually be in the theater and
see and feel viscerally the the music
that you felt as an audience member
sitting in a theater with live music and
and that was sort of a guiding principle
throughout and how we approach
filming the scenes and and and there was
a as steven said there was a
uh a lot of actual on-set
music production taking place another
challenge
was that john was
both director and a star
and so that was a very physically
demanding task that i don't even think
john really
realized he was you know getting into
and
and so it was it was a matter of
of recreating that intensity uh
on cam on film uh of the live show it
was also
um having it sort of organizing
the filming and the production of the
music around
physical limitations also budget it was
not a big budget film
and um and we had to be
fairly resourceful and and how we did
that how we approached that
um stephen when alex came on board
what was that um kind of
getting to know each other process like
the best part of the getting to know you
process was you know in addition to
to recording the songs which all
happened before the shooting
i scored the film i wrote the
instrumental score that went throughout
the film but
i had no equipment i had a four track
machine and i had a tv with a vcr
i didn't even i don't think they got a
remote control for my tv
you know so like the idea of like
pressing play and pressing record and
then getting to pick up my instrument
with my one microphone like it just it
was trying to write music
for it i i could write the music but i
couldn't write it really
for it and so um i actually
wrote all of the demo cues
in alex's office with alex recording me
while i would watch the movie there and
sometimes
write it there in the room you know it's
weird to think about now because like i
can
you can you can do almost anything with
scoring in a computer but
alex had what i think at the time was
very sophisticated
uh on computer technology for putting
the
for editing the music and sticking it
into the
into the picture but looking back and it
was very very primitive
sort of technology right alex it's like
certainly by today's standards
it was primitive but we had a lot of fun
with it it was appropriate
for for the circumstances in a way um
you had to be
pretty inventive and it was and it was i
just remember working really
being there after hours like we're in
your office until really late at night
we were and when it came to the score
there was also a question of
where we're getting away from the the
actual songs and everything but the
score is a big part of it actually and
even though there's not a lot of it it
plays a very important role
and and uh we were searching for what
that's
actually what the thematic material
should be and at a certain point
it it dawned on us that that really we
should take
the the melodic material from a song
that was already in the film
and use that as the as the the theme
the thematic material for for the score
so then when we get to the end it's just
this tremendous cathartic release which
i
i think you're not completely aware of
as an audience member but
it's there were so focused on the song
and
and that was beautiful actually the
world was just so
was so tight and coherent that it didn't
really it wasn't looking for new
material i wasn't looking for
a new song that wasn't looking for new
anything you know just
it wanted to be fleshed out and so yeah
like
um uh picking up on themes that were
already in the songs
uh particularly origin of love um
and using that in a few spots um i think
the flying music is
is unique unto itself um
and it had to bridge it had to somehow
be score but like the flying music had
to somehow
feel like it was in the same musical
world as the angry inch which was
fading out and the beginning of
wig in a box which when the fly music is
over you're there
basically it bridges those two worlds
not to feel like it
it was in that space without
and i'd saw without being without being
a song
and and like now i'm like when i when i
score a film like
i actually like i know how to do that
like it's a very like
it comes say someone give like gives me
a film with a with a lot of songs in it
i know how to figure out how to do
stuff that can that can go in between
the songs and it's not really that big a
deal but
but then it felt it felt like a really
heavy lift for me
um and i guess like like like
the other was like was it what
you did you did that live performance in
a spike lee movie right
alex there are many of them yeah i love
spike lee
and i knew i loved all those movies and
and
so one i just felt like i was in good
hands when we were
introduced and when you were like
brought into our our world but also
feeling like
knowing that we were doing it right and
figuring out that way
of mixing live performance and
pre-recorded performance
and mimicked live performance on the
set um like
you know that that was that was the
thing that you taught us how to do
and and well i've always been especially
with this
with this kind of music i've always
believed pretty strongly
that that it's to the extent that it can
be done it's important to
to to do live vocals uh
it just it's more believable when you
see it coming out of the actor's
mouth we had we had the
fortunate situation that that john was
both
a great actor and a great singer those
basic ingredients were already there
initially the producers of the film
were wondering why we couldn't just do
lip sync which is what most people were
doing at
certainly at the time and you know for
me it was just clear that again
that if we were going to recreate the
energy that we
felt in the theater and if we were going
to believe that what we were seeing on
screen was really happening
uh we had to do it with live vocals and
so we that being said as steven
mentioned we
we pre-recorded everything all of the
instrumental tracks we pre-recorded
john's vocals uh background vocals as
well
and um which so when we were filming
the musicians were actually miming their
instruments
but but john was singing live and we
were playing
back the instrumental tracks in the room
over
loudspeakers that the actors could hear
we were using real stage microphones
which are pretty good at isolating
the voice and um
and whenever
i'd say it's probably 90 or more
live vocals in the film um and we used
the pre-recorded vocals
uh because john you know it was just
very very demanding it's i don't know
that john
i'm sure that john didn't realize how
how demanding it would be
it's one thing to go through a show uh
from beginning to end in a couple of
hours it's another thing to spend
eight hours in the day singing the same
song over and
over again without blowing out your your
voice and so
whenever we weren't filming john we
would then we would be playing back the
pre-recorded vocals which is what what
the
what the uh the extras or the audience
and the scenes would be responding to
or um what what uh stephen and
and the rest of the band would be miming
to
the band did play everything note
perfect
i didn't say the drummer had
coming out of the drummer's monitor was
the drummer's part
loud enough so that for the audience
the sound of the drums seemed to really
actually be coming from the drums and
that was something that made it feel
more alive every day it felt like a live
like it felt like a musical production
unto itself i'm pretty sure that a lot
of the extras actually thought they were
hearing live music
like entirely live performance they
mentioned that like
they're they're like wow you guys play
great
like ah thank you what's one of your
favorite moments
of musically in the film well here's one
that
when you know with me singing tommy's
version of wicked little town
something really nice happened in that
recording i remember
bob coming up with an amazing guitar
like
did something to the guitar part that
just brought it to a new level
but it wasn't just bob and tim o'hara
was recording it and he got a great
sound and everyone played really well
and something about that recording and
then when sung by michael p
who has that beautiful face uh not
something but but he's lip-syncing to me
singing
like it just
i don't know it's got a it's as a that
record that one recording is a very
special sound to it i remember that
actually when we did that and it's very
vivid
you were in you were so in another place
as a performer you were really feeling
the part i remember that it was like you
were acting it in the studio and i think
that's why it feels that way
that makes sense because i also had to
method act the writing of the song
so singing it was was an extension of
that
like just to write it i had to go i had
to be somebody else
and so yeah i i remember being in the
studio
and and feeling that
going and being that other person and
then it just came out really special
how was it determined that you were
going to sing that role
for tommy i demanded it
what was there about that that that made
you want to demand it
i knew i could sing it right and
you know we had done the cast album with
atlantic records
and they actually only wanted to do the
soundtrack if
if we let like a one of their big stars
be tommy gnosis
and it would have been scott wieland and
he's like you know he would have sung
the [ __ ] out of it
but it definitely would have been scott
wieland like like
it wouldn't have been tommy nose's
singing it would have been scott whelan
singing
michael pitt could have mouthed it but
you'd have known who it was you know and
i wanted to do it so i just kind of like
we were very much when we shopped this
movie we i we had a
we took a lot of meetings and and gave
the pitch of what we wanted to do and
how we wanted to do it and
it was written into the contract that
that that
my band was going to be the band my band
broke up but they were going to be the
band in the movie
and on the recordings and if there were
any disagreements about musical elements
the film company could weigh in but that
i had the tie-breaking vote over the
director and the
film studio like this is weird like we
just demanded
like john demanded stuff and we did
manage and then we and then
new line was willing to give it to us
and atlantic wasn't and we ended up
selling the
uh alex all the the soundtrack later to
just to um hybrid records that got lost
i think in a card game
um but
but we would go around and give our
little pit our pitch to all these
to all the to all these film studios and
they would just kind of like look at us
like
who are these people they're crazy like
like you know we talk about like like
doing this sort of
improv john cassavetes thing where like
there's a lot of not
talking and whatever and and sort of
like what i'm doing right now and people
and then
they'd just be like
like really awkward lunches and then um
until finally new line was actually
interested
i found the right home yeah
so alex going
back uh to the beginning of being
brought on to
you know kind of create this film music
sound and at the same time ending up
selling the soundtrack i mean it sounds
like you
had quite an interesting journey with
this film i'm just wondering
what are some of the pieces along the
way that you found
particularly personal for you well first
of all i love the show
to begin with so when i was asked to
work on the film
i was thrilled i didn't know john or
stephen at the time
it was very complex and it got it you
know it was one of those projects where
i got to do
everything that i liked to do um which
is
frankly uh be involved in creating the
music
as opposed to some of the other roles
that
music supervisors often play like
clearances and it's you know and
licensing and so on so from for me i i
loved that
aspect of it i've always preferred that
part of it
the greatest thing that came out of it
frankly was getting to know stephen
um and becoming close friends with him
steven in fact produced the music
for my directorial debut a couple years
later pray for rock and roll which you
mentioned so
if you're lucky you get to work on a lot
of films and meet people but
it's not often that you actually meet
someone that you just
feel so uh such a rapport with
that that extends beyond just the the
working experience that you have
together so
at the same time it's a great you know
it's a great film it's a lot of fun i
like watching it with other people who
are discovering it
themselves for the first time and and
seeing that
it still resonates with people and it's
a big success in terms of what we set
out
to do we did create a movie that for
lack of a better word kicks ass
musically
you know and and uh and that's what we
wanted to do
you know and i think it does definitely
does that
kicks ass is definitely i think the
proper uh
phrase for this film so was hedwig a hit
right away or was it something that you
really had to work
to keep this project moving at what
point did it start to get a little
momentum of its own
we always were scraping by even when we
seemed to be a hit
it was always a heavy boulder rolling up
the hill even on broadway like
neil's run was sold out but when the run
started
his first night was sold out but the
second night was half sold
it wasn't until the first show ended and
the word got out that he was actually
really good the ticket started selling
it always requires a push you actually
can't let it just go of its own momentum
because if
you don't stay involved it kind of loses
whatever's special about it
it shouldn't feel like a piece of
commerce it should feel like a piece of
queer punk theater and the queer and the
punk
parts have to both be there like they
can't
can't just be queer and it can't just be
punk it's queer punk theater
and um and that that like
you know john and i are queer punks and
like not everybody else is so we have we
have to keep our fingers in the pie
so can you talk about uh again this
project started as kind of just a drag
performance
in in a very small space and then moved
to more of a theatrical venue
can you talk about how hedwig changed
in order to do that the big element that
came along with
was was getting a sort of organizing
philosophy for how to present it
which is the show is always happening
wherever the show happens to be
and so like when we were at the when we
did it on broadway the place that the
show was happening
was the belasco theater and edward
talked about being at the blasco theater
and then if there's the question well
how is this total nobody who's a failure
get onto a broadway stage well then that
that becomes part of this
that becomes part of the story that she
you know in this
in that case a show had closed
um a show it closed on opening night
um hurt locker the musical which is a
name that michael
made up um and uh and
their set was still there and and
hedwig gives a [ __ ] to the guy that
that runs the theater is actually the
guy that runs the whole schubert
organization
and he gave her the theater for justice
one night
um but like some of it was
was just like learning new ways to kind
of do the same thing like
when we first did it at fez undertone
cafe
and we had recordings of tommynosis off
stage like
like we didn't have a budget so john
came over to my house and we
hooked a microphone up to um a guitar
ramp with reverb so he could sound like
he was in a stadium
and then i put that on one channel of a
four track and then
on the other channels i recorded little
snippets of crowd noise
from the concert for bangladesh on
tracks two three and four and they were
never really long enough
to keep going so i would just keep cross
fading from two to three to four to two
to three to four to
three to four so that tommy could be
talking and saying his stuff
and the crowd could be responding it was
a makeshift version of what we ended up
doing
but it was that philosophy of being
where you are that we found
was the thing that worked does that
answer your question very much so
and and it's not the answer i would have
expected so thank you very much
you mentioned earlier that you know you
were both queer and both punk and all
that and
and obviously you had your music
sensibility and your music
side of the story and john was more the
performer and
writer perhaps uh you know but what do
you see as the things
that you and john brought to this that
that gave it the cohesiveness and that
gave it the
the yin and the yang so to speak i kind
of write
half the words that come out of hadwig's
mouth and john writes the other words
that could come out of hedwig's mouth
but it all has to sound like hedwig
so we had to be very much of one mind
and so a lot of a lot of the
work it came out of long conversations
like just long days and nights just
spent
talking about the various issues that
related to
the show and really getting into
dualities and and binaries and
breaking those open and and talking you
know looking at a lot of philosophy and
religious philosophy and all this stuff
and just long conversations so that when
you went to write
it wasn't necessarily that you went to
write with an instruction for
what was going to happen in the story
but
you were writing from the perspective of
coming out of these conversations where
where the two of us were just engaged in
this thing
what we ended up writing was just us
talking to each other
talking to each other in a way that we
thought would entertain our friends like
in the back of our mind
it was something going to be something
else but but
i think for me and i'm pretty sure for
john like the most immediate thing was
we're writing to each other and we're
going to show it to our friends
who know us and and and i think that's
why it has that
that feeling of yin and yang like
totally come together alex you you
observe them working together and
observe the making of the film what are
the different pieces that they each
bring to the
uh to the mix so to speak i knew a lot
about the creative
the collaborative process how the show
had been created
even before i met them and and i
uh knew that it would be
super stressful for both of them
and so uh because it was their first
film because film is
usually a director's medium you know and
here
here we had a situation where we had two
creative partners who were both equally
important to the success of the show and
and of the
of the concept in this case also stephen
was
a creative collaborator in the making of
the film and so that was also different
usually the the music creator is
not in that position you know so i i was
always very mindful i was always trying
to be respectful of
both john and stephen's equal
partnership in the creation of hedwig
the idea of hedwig
part of my role besides all the other
things we talked about was sort of
navigating the the cree the creative
process that each one of them would have
to go through to create the movie
you know so that each of them could do
what they had to do you know honestly i
spent a lot of time just trying to
understand where each of them was coming
from so that
that we could guide the the the from the
musical part of it the the
that process forward you know i i think
it's a testament to their relationship
they made the film and then they went on
and did the broadway show you know they
have
this is a very special entity john
and stephen and hedwig this world that
they've created
one of the things that was different
about the movie
was that our spheres stopped happening
in the same space
recording all the music for the film and
then turning it into an album
and then recording the score it was this
entirely other production
that had to fit with the film but they
were happening in different spaces and
john and i really didn't like see each
other
whereas when you're doing it on stage it
was
me and john and peter asking and miriam
and i would and i would have a piano
and a guitar and we would just be
sitting around a table and just
performing it
there you know and then you get onto the
stage and the band is there
and you're all working together in the
same room but we kind of like
kind of went off into our own spheres
and it's true with
any musical film it's actually more than
one production you have the film
production but before all of that
happens you have
you have you know maybe a couple of
months of the music production
you're rehearsing first the band that
you have to pre-record and
john who was singing then you have to
rehearse the actors
who are going to be in in the film and
all this has to happen
even before you can roll film and then
afterwards
the film is done and then we did
go and do all the album mixes which was
like
you know a whole other production there
were a lot of moments where
the the what was happening in the music
sphere
was separate from what was happening in
in the film
what's your favorite moment in the film
or some of your favorite
memories from the shoot one i loved
doing the improv
improvisational scenes that got cut but
there are all sorts of things
that we did that sometimes this ended up
being like an overhead shot in the hotel
room
uh therese had this great thing where we
were in addition to
touring around the same fish restaurant
her idea was that we were
in the same hotel motel
chain throughout the tour so the four
walls were always
the same four walls but as the tour went
down we had less less money
our room kept getting smaller so at the
beginning of the tour
we're in a kind of spacious room and
we're all kind of spread out and at the
end of the tour
the room is the width of the bed and
then there's just like a little place to
stand
that's just wide enough to open the door
to get in so it's the same decor
that just kept getting closer and closer
my memory of it
is that it was a blur it was a very
tight schedule
and there was so much to do it was
non-stop activity from morning to night
a lot of it was to be honest was also
getting john to pace himself
so that he wouldn't burn out because he
would throw himself into it
and again he was directing so you know
he was
looking at the monitor in costume you
know and
then having to run out and and sing and
perform
to be honest a little concern you know
he did he had to make it to the end and
so
so a lot of it was just getting him to
not use up all his energy in in one
moment
because he had a lot to do just filming
midnight radio was pretty intense you
know it was a
it was a puzzle actually of how to put
it together i still kind of feel like
this jolt
when i see that in the film especially
when we cut to miriam you know falling
back and the whole
the whole thing but alex is mentioning
like like getting john to pace himself
and how much work he's doing
on the visual side like therese was like
of all the people on the visual side she
was the most experienced
but i think alex probably brought
the the most film experience of anybody
to this movie you know i could feel that
when we first started
working together and it was very
important for me actually alex to
to to either impress you or to get your
approval but like
like that sense of alex has done this he
knows what this is like
i felt felt in very good hands and
bringing you into the world like it felt
right to bring you into the
into there i'm glad you brought me into
it thank you
yeah me too stephen alex i want to thank
you both for this conversation
um it's really great to talk about your
collaboration on this film with the
music and it's also great to see
that uh you've each found a friend so
congratulations and thank you very much
thank you thanks for thanks for asking
me to be a part of it
sorry you were uh up at four in the
morning but i don't think this is the
first time
[Laughter]
it's like the good old days steven
you